will bleep out every mention
because this is the zero Cloud podcast
zero clout chasing podcast and uh we
have a no Cloud policy and we did not we
did not want to do that wait but do we
have to use this face on a thumbnail no
we're gonna blur it out I think we have
to put like his face and then Reed's
face next to it and blur out Reed's face
and the thumbnails like The Man Behind
the Scenes or something ridiculous
[Music]
laughs
where we got to keep this in though
we're live now I would read I went and
listened to a bunch of interviews I did
the um I forget the guy's name I like
him a lot the financial YouTuber in
Vegas
um and then I watched Grand Stefan yeah
Graham Stefan and then I watched uh
Samir and Colin and then a few others
that you did including your channel and
I was like Sean
what if we just don't say the word
the whole time because he's great but I
know I I I've learned I've learned a bit
about it which you know let's just not
mention it once it's a bad business
decision not gonna get the views you're
not gonna get the clicks you're not
gonna get all that stuff but I don't
really care uh in fact actually it's a
great business decision to not be uh
chasing the algorithm so I say we just
talk about whatever was actually
whatever's actually interesting I think
it might be
no bleep so um yeah I think we might be
able to go the whole episode without it
let's try it's only up to you guys the
con the colon and Samira video is like
took off I I think we we expected it to
do well I don't think I expected it to
get whatever it's on 4.7 million views
but yeah you're like who's counting as
accurate as of today but who's counting
is it accurate yeah that's that's pretty
much the exact number
how do you how do you describe yourself
you're the founder of night media but
night media has a studio division you
have Knight capital I believe you have I
mean night media in itself it's fairly
simple it's just like an Endeavor or one
of these other agencies but it's a
different genre but how do you how do
you kind of like describe
what you do yeah we've we've started to
call ourselves a Creator holding company
so we at the center of the business we
represent talent and that's been
consistent since I started the business
in 2015 but we built out these other
verticals now which you mentioned we
have a venture studio uh which has
created things like feastables we have a
studio which is like making shows on
streaming services we have a venture
capital fund which is called night
Ventures it's a 20 million dollar fund
and then we announced night Capital
which is a 100 million dollar growth
fecal um so for us it's like a
platformized Creator holding company and
yeah it's I think early on it was much
easier to just say I'm a talent manager
now it's it's a little more confusing
when I'm like you know I can be
entrepreneurial I can be an investor I'm
also a talent manager so I kind of play
in a lot of different spaces I think
it's great because talent manager seems
to be a horrible business from what I
can tell I I've met a few Talent
managers and basically you you're either
um Talent poor in which case your
business sucks or you get Talent rich
but then your business always hanging on
a thread of this one whale or two whale
relationship and even then
um the value cat you might create a lot
of value but the value captures is
fairly small
um compared to what you're doing now
where you got this investing vehicle and
you got it you got all these other
components you said
Studio making shows for streaming what
have you guys made have you guys made
anything that's come out we did a lot of
stuff early on with YouTube originals
and that was kind of the emphasis of
like why we wanted to get into it
because Netflix and HBO and Hulu and all
these places starting ask starting to
ask us to make shows with them and so
you know creator games and some of the
other things that we did with YouTube
Originals led us into what we're
developing now which I don't know if I
can technically say anything about
what's coming out
um I'll just say there's like there's
cameras around constantly uh as well but
yeah we we have a few things like within
scripted one within non-scripted uh and
working on a few like different uh docu
uh memory type things right now so we'll
we'll have like a I think a pretty
decent slate by next year we'll see how
the
the writer strike and everything plays
itself out I think that one's been a
little interesting for us to get used to
but yeah we'll we'll have a bunch of
different things like coming out in what
is it summer of 2023 so sometime in
early 2024. is the agency business Sean
was he was joking but he's being serious
in that it's a bad business is that
actually a bad business because when I
would like I mean I don't I'm totally
outside of Hollywood when I see like Ari
Emmanuel I'm like it looks like your cat
his personal cash flow was pretty decent
on the rise versus a lot of like
startups you know you're you're kind of
in poverty until you have a some type of
a liquid event it seems like you guys
have some type of pool let's explain the
structure right so so what is the what
is the structure of a talent talent
agency so uh first you basically you you
recruit Talent you say okay you're uh
I'm gonna help you with your business
side of your operations or get you brand
deals or get you things that you that
you want now in the world of YouTube are
those exclusive or non-exclusive like
for example for an NBA player their
manager their agent is their exclusive
representative or they could fire them
but like no you can't have multiple
people bringing them deals it all has to
go through that person they get a cut of
everything so is it usually exclusive or
non-exclusive when it comes to YouTube
I think it depends on the type of
management company we've always kind of
sat on the fence of the exclusive and I
think the interesting thing about talent
management businesses is they're they
generate a lot of cash and so most of
the the management companies that you
look at that have actually started to
create things like um when you look at
just the big let's just look at the big
Hollywood agencies like three Arts
um entertainment 360 brillstein the ones
that have built some of the and launched
some of the biggest shows like it's
always sunny and friends and Seinfeld
and some of these things that they have
backend on that they will just have back
end and perpetuity on which those things
are ending but those businesses generate
a lot of cash I think the thing that
they've struggled with is like how do
you build something much bigger than
just this cash generating management
company and so when I started night the
management company was really like the
wedge of access into everything else and
that and that's really how I looked it's
like if you could represent the biggest
start with digital creators because me
like starting this business by myself
outside of the Hollywood System was very
hard to say I'm gonna go sign an actor
actress musician because that is very
much dominated by the Hollywood sphere
um and so I I knew that it would be much
easier for me to build a wedge in
digital and go represent you know I
started with dude perfect in 2013 but go
represent digital creators build that
wedge and then use that as the access
point to either continue building a
bigger management company you know the
verticals or to go build you know
something with interventure Studio have
a venture capital firm like the acts the
the management company gives you access
to everything else and that's how I saw
this in 2015 and I think that the
managers that realized that and there's
some some really like good ones that
have realized that map Carter I think
realized that pretty early on is like
the management business is kind of the
means to the end to build uninterrupted
and some of the other things that he's
doing with LeBron I think scooters
probably
the best example of like what Ithaca
became off the management company and so
that that's really how we've thought
about it is like you know management is
the core of our business but it's really
the like allows us to to have a wedge
that gets us into everything else
so that kind of proves the point right
like if a business has to be a means to
an end it's probably in itself not the
best business to stay at
um you mentioned a couple of those those
sound like pretty cool businesses so
Maverick Carter is LeBron's long time
friend I think High School I think he's
is he one of the part of the high school
crew for LeBron or did he come a little
later I think one of them came later I I
think he was I I don't know the full
story I think um Rich Paul was was came
uh came later after high school I think
Matt was actually a high school friend
and became his manager and they went on
to you know now have a production
company and a few other things it seems
like one of the few times that would
work out well by the way like your high
school buddy like taking the rain so
good good for them and um and so they
have a they have a a company that does
you know basically production and maybe
investing because I think they own a
bunch of a bunch of like pizza chains
and other things like that so they do
investing they do production you
mentioned Scooter Braun and his business
and so what what what is his business is
that like that sounds like that might be
a fantastic business what is it well
it's it started off I mean if everyone
knows the story probably that he met
Justin or or found Justin on YouTube
when he was really young reached out you
know the rest is kind of history there
but he he ended up building a music
management company that was really like
I think the the Cash Cow of that
business was more touring right with
Ariana Grande Justin Bieber some of the
other people and then he sold it to Hive
about I want to say a year ago or 18
months ago and they started
um either buying other management
companies they're buying music catalogs
they're doing a lot of different things
right now
um and he had he he did build quite a
few things with some of the talent I
know Justin and him built I can't
remember what the clothing business is
and there are some other like auxiliary
businesses that came out of Ithaca and
they also did a lot of investing a lot
of venture investing uh and so I so he
sold it for a billion dollars yeah he's
he sold his uh Media Company Ithaca
Holdings
um to to hide for one billion and I
think that's because it had those kind
of like like you said like Royal
royalties on
on the on the music itself not just like
the touring which might you know stop
tomorrow and who knows what happens in
the YouTube world there's no like
royalties structure correct like if
you're a talent manager for twitch
creators or for YouTubers
you get a cut of these brand deals 10 15
whatever it is but there's no like
royalties you have to like build other
IP to get the royalties right yeah when
there's there's also no back-end deals
like I said earlier where you know
brillstein or some management company in
Hollywood maybe helped launch it's
always sunny and now they have these
like residual
um checks coming in every single month
or every single year that also doesn't
exist in the digital space and so we had
to figure out like what that packaging
business was for us and we ultimately
landed on we think it's business
building like we think some of the
biggest outcomes for celebrities over
the last decade have been through
products right Beats by Dre probably the
best example of something I mean like uh
Vitamin Water was another one where it's
like that um athletes and different
people had equity in those businesses so
we think our packaging business is
essentially this business building uh
which we call night Labs uh which a lot
of different things have come out of now
but yeah the the management company has
then allowed us to build these
businesses with creators where we take
equity and we think think that like that
business is much more interesting long
term than just continuing to stack a
management business which some of these
companies do very well and you know
they're 30 40 50 million ebitda
businesses a year
um I think they're now trying to figure
out like what what do we either build on
top of this big cash generating business
or do we just keep doing it because the
partners every single year are making
three four five million dollars a year
do you um of your of this the night
night media night Studios of your holy
own thing how many staff do you have at
the moment
I believe we're just over 60. so 63
full-time uh within the night ecosystem
right now and and some of the teams are
relatively lean I would say our Ventures
team is is lean it's like three people
our studio team is still and that's like
our Venture studio is relatively lean
with about six uh and the majority of
the company is Talent managers and then
individual like pod systems where a
talent manager will have a junior
manager multiple coordinators maybe an
assistant under that pod and then that
pod will represent anywhere between I
would say five to seven creators on
average and are you managing someone as
well as running the 60 operation
uh I just managed uh that
happened about two years two to three
years ago where I was like this is
taking up way too much of my time and
also it's like it's also the best use of
my time and this was really like when we
had started
feastables was an idea we were you know
I was you know helping him produce
creator games there's just a lot going
on while he was also growing doing
multi-language all these other things
um and so that's when I like fully just
like kind of rededicated my time to
everything that was going on on his end
so you're able to get you know your cut
from managing him as well as from owning
the 60 person company
um yeah so so in in that regard it seems
like things are pretty good
so yeah things that I think are always a
little hectic and you know I'm I'm most
of my focus right now is on feastables I
think you guys have United I'm sure
you've seen the chocolate bars that to
us is like and I are
probably focusing the majority of our
energy on that business right now just
because it's growing so quickly and you
know we just launched in the UK we have
other Global launches that we want to do
this year and it's just building into
2024 and so I I knew this would
eventually happen where you represent a
Creator and then the business that
you're starting becomes the big
opportunity that you really want to
Chase and we think festivals is really
turning into that and so I've directed A
lot of my energy toward that business uh
and it's like slowly slowly consuming my
life at the moment before you started
night media what uh what interested you
what what were you going to start
instead of that well I grew up watching
Jerry Maguire probably like everyone
else and so I wanted to be a sports
agent like I wanted to represent Rod
Tidwell like I wanted to be that like
bigger than life you know agent
representing an NFL football player and
so that's I what I wanted to do and I I
knew that like because I played football
in college and freshman year of college
I realized that
guys are built different
um I one couldn't run a 4-3 I wasn't 225
pound wide receiver that was five or six
five and so I knew like playing in the
NFL was going to be very very difficult
just seeing the the level of high school
to division one football
um that I was at and so you know I
started seeing that a lot of the players
that I was playing with were going to
the NFL some of them were getting
drafted some of them were going to have
like NFL careers that lasted 10 years
and so I positioned myself to to be a
representative for those players and
that's really what I wanted to do and
then stumbled upon YouTube in 2013 and
kind of just became obsessed with it and
in college I didn't watch YouTube like I
was so focused on football didn't really
watch anything on the internet
um and that changed the trajectory of my
whole career I saw this uh t-shirt on
Instagram yesterday it said creatives
are the new athletes and somebody was
wearing that and uh I thought to myself
that's kind of a lame t-shirt but I see
where they're coming from uh you know I
I get what they're saying you know the I
just I don't know if you've seen Sam
these uh these deals that creators are
from twitch are signing with Kik
I heard you talk about it what is it
it's just a twitch alternative
so Kik is basically a twitch alternative
but the kind of the interesting part is
it started by this gambling company
steak so we've talked about steak before
remember
um it's this company that just
absolutely prints cash and one of the
main ways the main way that steak was
growing or one of the best growth
mechanisms was they would pay streamers
or give streamers money to gamble on
stake live on stream and so people got
to see didn't they give uh Drake like a
jet yeah the grave Drake like 20 million
dollars and whatever but the the issue
was you couldn't do it in America right
so a lot of the streamers and and they
would have to go to Mexico or Canada and
it's still very much like that you can't
do it in America yeah you gotta get on a
boat go to international waters and
start your stream like basically yeah
and a lot of the guys were doing this in
Mexico and so now kick basically came in
they started kick as like a distribution
like taco funnel on top of this gambling
business which
who knows if it's going to be legal in
the U.S in two to three years they
actually have steak.us that you can play
in America it's just a lot of the games
that you have on state.com are not there
but yeah a lot of controversy on uh on
this topic because twitch banned it and
that's why kickstarted is because twitch
banned all gambling on their website
it's like there's these stories
sometimes in business where it's like um
like I have a buddy who's like this uh
the guys who bought milk Road uh they
own uh one of them started this thing
called JM uh JM Bullion which is like a
gold it's the biggest website for buying
and selling gold online
and I was like how'd you do it what's
the origin story and he's telling me the
origin story and really when he started
he was just trying to be a lead gen for
um like somebody else would fulfill the
orders he didn't have any gold inventory
he wasn't shipping anything he was like
dude I'm an affiliate marketer I just I
get the lead from Google somebody places
the order I go tell the the company who
actually does this thing to go sell it
to go send it to him and what happened
was that they were they were kind of
yanking them around changing the rates
and eventually they just cut them off
and he's like oh my God they just killed
my business like
they don't want my customers like what
do I do he's like well either I take
this zero or
I create the whole like distribution I
create the whole supply chain myself I
basically go I get the physical
inventory I get the warehouses and we
start shipping this ourselves if that's
what they did they ended up becoming
bigger than the other company and I
think they bought them along the way
they bought that other company that had
rejected them and like went on to become
the number one site for this and it's
kind of the same
um
the same thing that you're talking about
here with like cake was using twitch as
like a distribution platform
and then when it didn't work they're
like all right we'll have to make our
own twitch which is kind of like a huge
Endeavor but what they're doing is
they're giving streamers these contracts
that
um I kick the tires on this to figure
out if it was real because they gave xqc
who's one of the top uh twitch streamers
like a reported two-year 100 million
dollar contract what so that means that
this guy's making more than LeBron James
playing for the Lakers this year like
per year that would be the the deal and
same thing and and crazier than that is
that he doesn't have to he doesn't have
to stop streaming on Twitch he could
still stream on Twitch right and so when
you first hear this this sounds crazy
it's like you signed a non-exclusive 100
million dollar deal for some kid in his
bedroom playing video games that sounds
insane and then they did that with a
bunch of other streamers so a bunch of
other streamers are also making you know
10 million 20 million 30 million dollars
a year to stream on Kik right now and
the big question is will this strategy
work uh you know we'll kick become a
thing will it just die will this give
steak a bunch of customers or is this is
the website because kik.com according to
similar web has like 150 million monthly
uniques already yeah so this has been
going for how long like six to eight
months maybe yeah like within this year
basically they've been they've been
doing this and how do they get that much
traffic that fast I mean that's one of
the faster growing websites out there
yeah so so what happened here was um two
two Twist streamers that when they
banned gambling couldn't stream on
Twitch anymore because their brands were
essentially built around state which one
was train wrecks who had a really loyal
following on Twitch and then they also
then signed eight in second and so train
wrecks and Aiden started streaming on
Kik which drove a lot of people over to
that website and then the xqc uh the mid
like everyone else that they started
signing was just driving more and more
traffic and it started to just become a
thing of like anti-twitch go to kick
though also the one thing to point out
is AD revenue on Twitch uh if you're if
you're a partner on Twitch used to be 70
30. they brought it down to 50 50 which
sparked outrage on the internet and then
tick came out and said we're going to do
90 10 for everyone it doesn't matter if
you're a partner or not we're going to
lose an incredible amount of money on
the content business and just make sure
that state.com remains like the cash cow
and so that's like the the big thing
that they have against twitch is like
they don't really care if they have a
profitable streaming business or not but
do they how'd they find it how'd they
finance this entire thing I thought Sean
that we had talked about these guys was
it wasn't wasn't the founder of steak is
it like a 28 or back then we're I think
we were talking about a year ago it was
like a 26 year old guy who bought like a
50 million dollar mansion in Australia
is it still like a bunch of young guys
doing this without financing I mean not
without financing the financing is
Stakes I mean outside finance and 800 it
had like an 800 million dollar dividend
last year or something like that
business is just Ultra Ultra profitable
and so their competitive Advantage is
basically that
they they're like reset their business
model is not ads on Kik or subscription
cut it's can we funnel these users to
come gamble on our in our casino and we
have a casino twitch doesn't have a
casino that's the bet that they're
making the other thing that I because I
tweeted this out I was like I said this
thing is fishy I said they're paying XTC
100 million dollars for two years of
non-exclusive streaming are they a lying
B is this like incentive based or some
like tiered like you know some some like
stock deal they're inflating the value
of the stock or something like that to
make the number set the headline number
sound really big
are they just laundering money is that
what this is like what is going on here
and basically it was here's the here's
what the the answer was basically it's a
combination of cash and Equity so their
Equity part might go to zero so that
that part of the deal might go to zero
um or it has incentives where it's like
it's based on the number of customers
you bring over
um and the second part is that the
non-inclusive part is basically so that
he could just like funnel traffic from
twitch to Kik so if we just turned off
like uh this is like a big deal like
when Microsoft
poached ninja from twitch he had to stop
streaming on Twitch that day and like go
stream on this other platform and so
most people on Twitter just like kind of
like outside out of mind
yeah some people followed him over there
to check it out but like ultimately
their habit was still built on Twitch
what these guys are doing is different
he streams on Twitch and he says all
right I'm gonna finish my stream or I'm
gonna like play the big game over on Kik
and then he just like it's like a call
to action it just funnels a bunch of
traffic over over and over when I was at
twitch we did the same thing when we
were losing foothold in one market in
Brazil we acquired this huge YouTube
streamer and I was like
um and they were and it was an exclusive
deal but he started streaming on YouTube
while he was streaming on Twitch and I
was like and at first people in the
company were like yo what the hell man
you just spent all this money millions
of dollars like signing the streamer and
he's still streaming on YouTube over
there for free like what's the deal and
I was like actually wait this is
probably excellent because all we have
to do is just get him to like block part
of the screen or like end his like do a
cliffhanger and be like I'm finishing
this over at twitch and he'll just keep
bringing traffic over and that's what he
did we just basically let him violate
his deal because we realized actually he
was smarter than us that was a better
funnel for us than than an exclusive
deal would have been that's insane read
what these I imagine you've talked to
these you know these State guys well is
this like a Sam bakeman free type of
company where they're or an FTX company
where there's like a bunch of crazy
young kids or is this like a dialed in
thing what are these guys like I don't
know them well enough honestly to know
if it's like gonna become a problem I
would say that from my conversations
with them they seem like they have this
thing under control generating a lot of
cash FTX thing I company wasn't
generating any cash when Bitcoin went
down it was like just completely fell
apart but I don't mean is it a scam but
I mean like young people just being wild
uh you know like imagine a 27 year old
making 800 million dividend uh just like
a a wild child type of setup
I haven't seen that from them but it
seems like they're a little bit more
laid back uh in Australia don't really
communicate with a lot of people so I I
haven't seen that behavior
um I mean that could change I'm just I
and I know I know way too much about the
deal structures and everything else uh
and how this stuff works but I I would
I'm pretty confident in kick over at
least in the next couple of years we'll
see where this goes if they continue to
want to do that business I I would
imagine steak is going to just continue
to get so big that maybe kick eventually
becomes a distraction I don't know
um but I I would say they'll double down
on stake.us over the next like 18 months
as like States open up and allow them to
start doing this that's insane there was
also a secondary business called rubat
as well uh that was essentially the
thestate.com competitor I'm not 100 sure
what happened to rubat uh but it's still
around and so there is other businesses
like steak steak just completely won
because they were able to sign the
biggest creators like train they signed
Drake which you guys said uh it's at the
moment it's a runaway train they're kind
of taking all the market share in one of
your other podcasts you'd mentioned how
um
uh you're like well a lot of creators
they think well I have an audience I'm
going to launch this product and you're
like well that can work for a couple
months but if you do a good job this
turns into a proper company and the real
challenge uh you're saying the real
challenge that I'm in is finding amazing
Executives to actually run the companies
and build these into real companies you
said for feasibles I think you said you
had the president of RX bar to come and
be the CEO uh for uh the burger business
or the restaurant business you partnered
with someone and you also sounds like
had a president or a CEO of that company
what type of deals are you striking with
some of these CEOs to make it worth
their while uh to to to do this yeah
thankfully a lot of them realize the
opportunity when they come into these
businesses they know that there's an
unfair advantage in go to market because
the creator has hopefully built this
massive platform already that gives them
instant distribution and just consumers
and so a lot of the people that we
interview for CEOs are actually
incredibly excited about the opportunity
and are willing to leave their big job
at PepsiCo or wherever that is and so
how the deals are really structured is
very similar to any other business you
you have like the a cash basis that
you're paying them and then you also
negotiate some piece of equity uh over
of like a four-yearvesting schedule and
so we've had a lot of success doing that
but for the most part we usually don't
have to explain the competitive
advantage to the business like when we
start meeting these individuals they
already know they've seen it they saw it
with prime they're seeing the feasibles
they've seen it with happy Dad a lot of
the individuals that were interviewing
already know uh and so it makes it a
little bit easier for us to get them to
leave that specific job but it's it's
structured very similar to like what a a
CEO would potentially make if they came
in and ramp startup and are you funding
the company with a bit we fund up to a
certain amount what's that amount
usually it honestly depends on the
business I would say it falls anywhere
between the 250 250 on the low end a
million on the high end so festivals you
fun that that start with just a million
bucks you think yeah the the the big
issue with feastables was and this is
the issue we're now having with some of
our consumer products is retailers
instead of so if you if you started a
chips business or whatever and you
didn't have a Creator attached to it or
anyone attached to it they give you gave
you an unfair advantage on go to market
you would go to a retailer and they
would say we want to test you in a
hundred stores or we want to test you in
200 stores and from a cost per
perspective to fund the PO wouldn't be
that like it wouldn't put that much
strain on the business the issue that we
had with feastables was Walmart was
willing to put us in all 2 650 store or
4650 Stores
um it right when we launched and so
that's becoming the issue with some of
these businesses is that how do you fund
the PO of six seven eight million
dollars right out of the gate to meet
that retail demand and so that's the one
that we've we've had to either raise
Capital uh go bag a bank to give us the
money as like uh Pia as like a PO loan
and so that that's kind of the issue
that we've run into and even with
feasible is like we raised a small
amount of capital and it was really just
to fund the 4 million chocolate bars
that we ended up selling in season one
that sold out in I think it was 45 days
that was the biggest cash constraint to
the business let's talk a little bit
about prime so Prime
um
seems to be just taken over
um I it really really impressive I don't
know
um
how much we've talked about it on here
before but can you just explain
what's going on with Prime in a way that
would for somebody who's kind of out of
the loop or maybe you know vaguely heard
of it but doesn't really truly
appreciate like the the extent it's it's
what it's doing yeah so if you don't
know what prime is prime is a hydration
drink that was started by uh Logan Paul
who many people are probably familiar
with and then KSI who's based out of the
UK but I would say the most popular
Creator to ever come out of that region
and so you know they very notably like
boxed against each other multiple times
they were enemies and the story was that
I'm coming together to start this
business and the the company that they
partnered with actually made an energy
drink called Aulani new that's actually
uh and you see it next to Prime I think
in every Grocery Store retail chain I go
into it's like Prime City or Lonnie news
sits right next to it and so the
founders of Alani knew basically created
this drink that they did called Prime
and Logan Paul and KSI came in really is
just the marketing engine they don't do
anything operationally for the business
they really just Market it and it it
became and look like a clout piece to
hold a bottle of prime like now these 10
12 13 year old kids have to have it they
have to drink it and we've seen some of
the I mean I saw an article about uh
people saying the FDA needs to go
regulate this business because it has
too much caffeine in the energy drink
and so now now there's just a lot of
stuff going on about the company but
it's grown an incredible amount I think
I I can't remember what Logan said on
one of his podcasts but I think they did
45 million dollars in Revenue in January
of this year and that was that was the
last thing that I'd seen them say
publicly about the business I think he
said if I remember correctly Sean we
talked about it it might have been six
months ago I think he said like 200
million for the year is that right yeah
that's the number that's one number we
had heard but 45 million obviously would
put them on a totally different
trajectory than that so yeah it appears
to be just an absolute monster
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better who's the
who's Logan Paul's manager who's who's
his name's Jeff he's he's on the podcast
he's been the same manager for a long
time uh Logan talks about him quite a
bit and so if you if you watch some of
Logan's older videos too he would
periodically show up and so they've been
together for a long time and Jeff put
together that deal and it's been
incredibly successful we'll we'll see
how it ends up I I don't know I would
imagine they're going to want to
continue to do this thing for another
couple of years and then probably sell
it and those guys who created the drink
you said they created a lot new but that
wasn't that big uh like it seemed I
remember when Prime first came out I was
like who are these guys and it's I think
it's two dudes right who are the
founders of that yeah
um and though they didn't really have a
huge hit before that how did they even
secure that deal and why why did they
partner with them over like you know
some more established thing do you know
I honestly don't know
I've never had that conversation with
Jeff of of why did why partner with this
company instead of doing it yourself I
think I I would imagine what happened
was this company presented them with the
opportunity and it was something that
really resonated with Logan and then I
remember the story of him saying he
called KSI and tried to get him on board
which he did and so it probably is just
right place right time Logan was ready
to lean into something else and Logan's
on a lot of different business ventures
over the last five years I mean this one
obviously is Far and Beyond the most
successful but I again I would imagine
right place right time they like the
products liked the got along with the
individuals who are operating the
business
and the the partnering with KSI
um were they just actually friends the
whole time and the whole boxing thing
was just you know just a sort of
Frenemies thing or like because that's
kind of a genius move right like you
kind of have to give credit to be like
you know what will make this even bigger
because normally let's say you're one of
the biggest YouTubers
those people tend to have like a bit of
an ego I am distribution I don't need
anybody else to do this I don't need to
split the pie especially with my enemy
so
that's kind of interesting well what's
going on there no total uh no uh they
did not like each other uh the boxing
beef was real they were definitely
enemies and from my understanding of the
story and I've only heard Logan's side
of this I haven't heard KSI speak about
it it took a lot of convincing for Logan
to get KSI on board because there was
still a lot of animosity between the
relationship there I mean a lot of stuff
was set a lot of personal things were
said about girlfriends and parents and I
mean it was a very personal beef that
went on in this YouTube space for a
while and so I think that's why it was
so surprising when those two came
together to launch Prime because it was
the last two individuals you had ever
thought to partner together on a
hydration
he said my Pokemon was a PSA eight it
was it got ugly yeah yeah but now it's
like for for us it's it's been helpful
because you know we uh they launched in
Australia and it went incredibly well
for them they launched in the UK it went
very well and so feasible was like we're
probably six to eight months behind
because they you know had a product and
launched a lot sooner than we did but
it's it's allowed us to then go into
those conversations in Australia UK
southeast Asia where and the retailers
have already had massive success with
prime where it's a much easier
conversation for us to explain to them
why they should take feasibles where I
think if we were the first ones coming
into the in the industry like into
woolies that in Australia probably a
little harder conversation pre-prime
well and that Prime seems like an
amazing category uh like that to me uh
the drink the hydration drink water
basically like fancy water is a better
category than chocolate bars how do you
think about categories that you're going
to go into like
um do you think that's a better category
and also like how do you choose what
category to get to is you could
basically promote anything dude when we
we we did the thing with Sean organized
this thing and he brought a bunch of
feasibles I ate about eight of those
things in one night I was I felt
horrible the next day I did eat dinner I
just ate all this chocolate so at least
for that night it felt like a good
category yeah well okay see I have to
back up to explain how this all started
and so you know this started with my you
know in a parking lot kind of
brainstorming ideas while he was it was
in between him filming this video that
never got posted
like most videos that like just got
filmed and never people never saw it but
anyway we we came up with this idea
where we wanted to launch a snacks
company and we wanted to build this
constant idea around launching the
snacks company and childhood bars to us
felt like the right category for a
couple reasons like one is it's a
massive business like it's a 26 billion
dollar industry it's it's very holiday
seasonal dependent which if you're a
parent going into a store for Halloween
or for Easter or something like that
it's like Hershey's is sitting here and
feasible is sitting here and you have a
8 9 10 12 year old son daughter like
it's a no-brainer like you're gonna buy
the feasible's chocolate and so that
that was one reason another thing is the
50th anniversary of Willy Wonka was uh
in 2021 and so the initial idea was
let's put golden tickets in chocolate
bars and sell that and give away a
chocolate factory which became just a
thing in itself of you know buying a
warehouse and turning into a chocolate
factory it was no easy feat
um but that that really kind of sparked
the conversation of okay well if we're
gonna build this on this Chocolate
Factory giveaway with a chocolate bar
um what are the other categories that we
can eventually go into the cookie really
came because you know had this joke on
his channel and it's been since the
beginning is you guys see it in the
banner it's like subscribe and I'll give
you a cookie and so we we wanted to
venture into cookies next it's it's not
I would say as big of a focus for us as
chocolate I think we're really trying to
build out seasonality and chocolate
we're trying to build multi-pack and
chocolate I don't think people truly
understand how big Hershey's actually is
uh and how dominant they are in the
space like they truly dominate chocolate
because they also own Reese's which is
like if you walk into chocolate island
Walmart Target Kroger wherever you see a
giant wall of orange and a giant wall of
bread it's like you very clearly uh
those two businesses or those two Brands
dominate the child aisle and so we
thought it was a good space for us to go
at because it wasn't
um it wasn't so oversaturated by 20 30
40 different companies is like we really
knew who we were competing against we
were like we're competing against
Hershey we need to be more Innovative we
need to build this gamification layer we
need to build a better product that has
higher quality ingredients we did we
knew like what the road map looked like
to compete with them it's been a lot
harder than we thought just Global
chocolate supply chain I think was
something Jimmy and I knew nothing about
thank God for our team that like
understands this that we've been working
with but yeah I think we'll we'll
definitely go I don't know if Jimmy said
anything to you guys when you were in
Greenville but I mean there's a road map
of products that we're going to do over
the next like two to three years we're
trying to figure out like what the
rollout strategy is going to be but for
2023 and you're going to 2024 chocolate
is the main priority right and getting
more space in retail I gotta take back
what I said I think it's a great
category you convinced me I was wrong
that was great uh I actually I think
what you guys are doing is really smart
there by the way Hershey's makes like
eight or nine billion a year in Revenue
off of uh they're saying and the reason
I think it's in great category actually
based on what you said was the audience
fit but also uh just like how old that
competition is and like you know you
didn't say this but like if I'm Mars or
I'm Mondelez or I'm Hershey's
um
you know I look at my acquisition
targets my m a targets there's not many
and um I think this is an opportunity
where I don't think the business itself
is going to generate a ton of profit
just because
uh physical goods and you know they're
like as you scale up it's like you know
it's not the thickest margins
but I do think this is like a business
where you're going to look up and sell
it for 500 million dollars or something
like that someday if you wanted to
you'd actually be surprised the
chocolate actually is a it's a pretty
good marketing business for us and I
mean Hershey is still you know they
probably turn off six to eight hundred
million dollars in profit every single
year and have been doing this for 50
plus years and so
we yeah it's it's been challenging for
us but we understand like what the road
map is we really think that
and we don't know how Hershey is going
to compete with us seasonally uh that's
like one thing big for us like
Halloween's gonna be big for us this
year uh we're doing a lot of different
sweepstakes and promotional things and
so you know for us if we can win those
months like October then becomes 100 to
200 million dollars just in a single
month and we can put our full force into
just October and then into holiday and
then you turn it around and you're like
okay now like what are we doing for
Valentine's Day what are we doing for
Easter uh and so these are all like the
conversations that we've been having
over the last year
what number would kind of cross the
threshold of all right we should take
this acquisition seriously if one of
those guys came to you at the end of the
year
I don't think he takes a multi-billion
dollar acquisition right now I there's
just too much upside in the business
right now just for feasibles yeah it's
just it's
the amount of opportunity for us not not
only okay let's just just I'm just
talking domestically so now let's just
let's talk about just the world right
chocolate is is popular like globally
and we haven't really talked about this
yet but I know he talks about on your
guys podcast is we launched all these
multi-language channels there's there's
really a method to the madness here is
like you know we now dub in I think 16
different languages uh including
Japanese and French and Hindi those are
all markets for us that we're pushing
into over the next like 12 to 18 months
and so the opportunity for us is just
way too big to even look at an
acquisition at the moment because for us
like Asia is is a huge Market the Middle
East has actually become one of our
highest growing markets at the moment
which we're now figuring out like what
are the points of distribution and then
we're eventually going to be able to
just specifically Market to those
regions like we're going to be able to
put a video file up and it's going to be
the Japanese dub but instead of being
like hey go to your local Walmart and
Target it's gonna be like our um our dub
artists in Japanese which is uh the
voice actor of naruso saying oh you can
go buy it at your local 7-Eleven or
other convenience stores available in
Japan and so we're going to make
everything very localized and so to us
like we're like I haven't even rounded
first base yet to what this business
opportunity is and so I don't know we
haven't even had like acquisition tart
like isn't even a thing well when we
when we all hung out with him he was
talking about he was talking to the same
thing uh I don't know if he was saying
feasibles but just like his Enterprise
you know he threw around crazy ideas of
like maybe IPO maybe sell for billions
of dollars I don't know like but he
approached it in a
this isn't an insult but it was very
naive like he sounded like uh an
innocent like oh I'm just gonna do this
and then this and then this that's it
like it's it's gonna work and I remember
but but I found it to be like um
believable hey like I believe that he
actually could potentially do that which
is crazy but B I felt like his ignorance
a little bit about business was actually
a massive
um
tool for him a little bit where I was
like man that's like you'd be one of the
biggest things in the world and in his
brain he's like well yeah what do you
what do you expect uh and I don't know
if that's maybe naive is not the right
word but there was almost an innocence
about it uh that I I really appreciated
do you think you have that same kind of
mindset with this or or do are half the
things that you guys are working on not
just you and him but your rest your
artists or the rest of your um uh folks
on your team are you like I don't know
if we could pull this off but whatever
let's just try and get into it we'll see
what happens uh I he's probably we're a
little bit different in that regard I
think I'm a little bit more of a realist
in terms of you know knowing how hard
these things are to build knowing how
hard these things are to sell
I said ultimately it's going to be his
decision you know if he wants to sell
this thing or not but I I think there
there is a level of him and I are very
naive to to at least when we enter the
chocolate Arena we didn't really have a
good understanding of
what we needed to create how we needed
to compete and I actually think that was
an advantage for us because we were just
running as fast as possible trying to
get product out and we made a lot of
critical
um I would say decisions that were
either big positives or big negatives
and we were able to go change the
negatives very quickly I think one is I
think you said you didn't even have
customer support the day you launched or
something like that we didn't have
customer support in
which we then learned in feastables like
okay in a little different business so
we we had a full customer social support
team when we launched feastables
thankfully and you you know you've done
a couple of these now and I think uh
I've always been amazed like some
creators are much better promoters than
others and it's not just like it matters
like in a couple different ways
sometimes if your brand is like
I'm super real and authentic anytime you
say anything promotional the audience is
like yo sell out you know you can't do
that and other people whose brand is to
be more of a spectacle or more
interesting they can get away with a
little more but there's also just the
Creator's motivation so as Brands throw
money at creators to you know tell
people hey swipe up and do this hey
swipe up and do this you know like at
some point
um I think everybody becomes a little
numb to it the audience and the Creator
what I've been impressed with is for
something like feastable or I also felt
this way with prime I felt like with
prime Logan Paul
is like the CMO and he's like he's
looking for every Edge he's got it
almost you know like I don't think they
own the majority of their company I
think they own a small minority in that
company but
he almost treats it like a majority
owner I remember when he went to like he
goes to like uh you know the WWE thing
or UFC fight he's got his prime bottle
with him and then he'll do something
that he knows is gonna he'll like
embarrass himself so he gets memed like
a million times on Instagram but he's
like yeah I got meme but I was holding I
was holding Prime wasn't I he's like you
know basically it was all intentional
he's like looking for these little edges
and that's very different than
you know the old days when uh you know
an influencer holds up some detox tea
and just says you know hey try this
um what do you think is the difference
in buying and that kind of like that
mindset of like I'm going to use my
engine to promote this like to level 100
what have you seen is the difference
there and and how does that happen
yeah I mean there's also just a
different level of excitement when you
have ownership in the brand versus you
don't whereas like there's a cash
exchange for you to promote audible.com
you're not going to be as excited you're
not going to put as much time creatively
into this let's just say add read that
you will if you own the business and so
I I actually first saw this when we did
figure on the app I'd seen him do a lot
of like we had done a lot of mobile
Integrations on the channel and then
when we did figure on the app it was our
thing uh we owned it it was like our
competition explain what it is for
somebody doesn't a figure on the app was
we created this mobile game where a
person puts their finger on their cell
phone uh and the last person to take the
finger off the phone went 100 Grand and
there's little bombs that would pop up
so you'd have to like move your thumb
around to just avoid objects that would
pop on your phone it ended up lasting 72
hours and then someone won 100K but uh
level of excitement and level of
promotion just went to the next level uh
he was you know telling people why they
should download it and he was you know
messaging people back on Twitter who was
like Hey I just downloaded I'm ready for
the game he was responding and so
there's like a much more there's much
more depth to the level of excitement on
the Creator side and you really see that
with Prime and it would do with
feastfuls and you see it with also happy
dad with nelk uh they're going all in on
happy Dad the podcast is essentially
built around you know happy Dad is
everywhere for each podcast episode and
I I do think the future is creators
starting businesses the issue is like
most of the time it's just gonna happen
at the top uh where you know we are
seeing some interesting businesses for
like a mid-tier Creator who maybe isn't
to the level of Logan Paul or nelk but
they're you know cars versus bids or
something like that where it's you know
the channel maybe has two three million
subscribers doing 500k video and they're
gaining a lot of traction on that type
of business what are some other examples
like that
um in in the Creator space in the
Creator space cool Creator businesses
that are not just like well I'm the most
famous guy on Earth so whatever I say
Works uh you know what what are some
like we had Dr [__] for Carson bids
what are some other examples like that
uh there's one called uh rare candy it's
with Leon Hart who's you know he's a a
relatively large Pokemon style Creator
and he has a marketplace where you can
buy Pokemon cards and do Pokemon
unboxing so it's similar to what not and
how it it works but it's you leonhardt
owns a large piece of that business
um I I mean to go back to the top like
Emma Chamberlain coffee I think is
another one it's like very organic or
talks a lot about coffee and now I'm
starting to see a lot of businesses pop
up on the smaller end where it's maybe
you have a channel that
washes Windows right so it's like a tick
tock Creator who maybe it does ASMR
through like washing a house or washing
windows and they use it as like this top
of funnel in like a city where all these
individual houses or all these people
are not reaching out to be like oh this
person's in Austin I'll pay them 400 to
come pressure I've seen a lot of those
for pressure washing they're they're all
over the place and the grass cutting uh
like lawn mowing yeah lawn mowing
vending machines uh seeing a lot of like
little small Niche businesses getting
built but I I think these businesses are
much bigger than people think they are
um they're they're gaining like even in
the pressure washing like meeting
creators and they're making like 20 30
000 a month just from pressure washing
homes and then all of a sudden you know
they hire two or three other people
because the demand is so high for people
you know booking them out to to clean
their home that they start to hire
employees and then it becomes a real
business that once just started as like
one Tick Tock video of them pressure
washing pressure washing their own house
are you from the Midwest
I am from North Dakota you're the first
person on the Pod that says the word
wash like I do with an r i I grew up 40
miles from the Canadian border so I'm
probably just as Canadian as American at
this point uh I get made fun of all the
time for saying that word that way that
I've embarrassed even say it but I just
heard you say it
um are there any companies uh or any
Creator businesses out there that are
shockingly large that many people don't
know about yeah so one that I was wildly
impressed by that was much bigger than I
initially thought was Darman so it's the
largest scripted YouTube channel on the
internet and so it's it's all like it's
daily uploading but it's long form
scripted storytelling and so I I really
didn't understand like how big of an
operation that was and how many you know
people and how many sets and just the
sheer volume of content coming out of
that business that that was one I was
pretty surprised by and if you don't
know what it is I remember when I first
saw it I was like are people watching
this and then I just have been paying
attention it's slowly growing it's
almost like the Hallmark or Lifetime
channel but for like how do you spell it
what is it
he has 18.5 million subscribers it's
like um
it's there's like a lesson to be learned
in like each episode is that right read
yeah he used to do something completely
different right like Dar was doing
something completely different and then
he's he he pivoted into this if he yeah
found found his footing and scripted
storytelling on YouTube uh more
fast-paced a little bit more light on
the scripted uh like storytelling aspect
because it's like more content and
volume I'm pretty sure this guy had a
giant weed business before this uh
makeup actually but I think he also had
a weed but his wife is also an
influencer I think she has a makeup
business yeah I'm pretty sure this guy
had a cannabis business I I don't know
if I I got that right but why why funny
yeah we grow he started uh he started we
grow it it's sold uh hydrophonics and
marketed for growing medical marijuana
that's funny why uh why is this guy
impressive to you read what what's the
behind the scenes information just the
sheer like the sheer size of the
production company you know people
people say it like oh you can build you
know production entities on top of
YouTube and creators are hiring
employees you know it's like this is a
good example of massive production
entity built on YouTube cash flow
positive making money you know I think
most people thought that you know you
couldn't do scripted storytelling on
YouTube and actually make it a
profitable business just because it
didn't make sense with how the ad
Revenue works and how the splits worked
and he's really figured it out and it's
it's hard because you have to upload
daily and you have to average two three
four five million views per video to
start making significant amount of money
but they've really figured it out on a
large scale did they get the revenue up
or did they get the expenses down what
did they do different than you would
have expected or what did they what was
the trick from what from what I've seen
in the scripted space on YouTube and and
this is also like in the in like the
streaming services scripted content is
very expensive you know you you have
writers on staff like it's usually long
time lines they they figured out how to
create content on a scripted basis much
quicker and much more cost efficient
where it's like dar's doing a lot of the
writing they have a lot of just like
part-time talent that comes in
periodically and acts uh and then they
also just like figure out how to do this
with their own sets so they're not
renting space like they actually built
their own sets in uh in in LA and
they're just just reusing the same sets
I mean if you watch a lot of Darman
videos You'll see the school you'll see
the the movie theater uh there's a
there's like a gas station there's a lot
of like staple sets that just continue
to show up and they do a really good job
just repurposing those sets that's
amazing I can't believe I remember
seeing this guy when it was coming up I
never in a million years would have bet
that this would have been a good one
what what are uh what are some other
businesses out there that you've seen
that are just shockingly interesting so
this wasn't it's not a channel that's a
business yet but I I stumbled upon it a
couple weeks ago it's called Ryan Hall
y'all and he was a former meteorologist
and it's like a channel based on just uh
what weather uh is happening across the
country be different things that you
should know about like the hurricane
season and how it's going to affect the
the like uh the southeast and you know
it's I I'd seen channels try and do this
in the past he's the first one that's
gaining like tremendous traction and you
can see it in the views per video you
know it's like two three million views
per video just on just talking about
different weather patterns and this this
is one that could I think become pretty
interesting long term whether he decides
to build something on top of that and
I'm guessing it's like a very uh minimal
team it's probably him plus an editor
what is he doing because uh weather's so
local people you know what do I care
about the weather in Toledo right unless
there's a natural disaster like you know
what do I care so how was he how is he
doing this this is incredible more of
like the talking about just the whole
the things that you should know about
tornadoes or these are the most
dangerous uh weather patterns of the
year of the month so he talks more
holistically about just the entire
industry it's not really localized I
mean I'm sure he could start localizing
channels but that becomes a much smaller
opportunity you have to you have to make
these videos appeal to everyone and he's
done such a good job at that but these
type of like little niche channels that
start to pull a tremendous amount of
views pop up every single month on
YouTube I mean the vending machine one
was something that I went down that
rabbit hole and farming I went down the
farming Rabbit Hole what are the what's
the farming and vending machine once
yeah so farming Cola corn star I'll hit
you with a few ones so Millennial farmer
is probably the one that I watch the
most and
uh I grew up on a farm and so it wasn't
that interesting to me because I know I
know all the stuff that he's doing but
for a normal person on the coast who has
it doesn't know about you know
cultivating or anything like that I
think it's it's really interesting to
them and so he's one that's it's more I
think appeals more to an older crowd uh
Cola corn star is another one that
probably appeals to a little bit younger
demographic where it's a little bit more
like ranks and things like that on the
farm uh and then Lauren farms uh female
Channel also kind of showing like in the
in the daily aspect
um of just what do you do on a farm and
so there really is a space for all types
of content on the internet now that's
why the the argument of the internet is
so oversaturated it's hard to break
through as a Creator like I just have
never bought that argument because on
Tick Tock and YouTube shorts I'm seeing
things that continue to break through on
a weekly basis and then people are
figuring out how to turn it into an
actual Channel That's profitable and
we're seeing it with people like Ryan
all y'all who you know nobody would have
ever thought that a Channel about the
weather could pull 3 million views of
video but yet here he is doing it time
and time again well that kind of makes
sense that one of the comments on Ryan
uh Ryan Hall's videos that said uh man
the weather channel has really lost its
way I'm so excited that Ryan is is doing
it this way which is funny that someone
like and that was actually the most
upvoted comment which means a lot of
people pay attention to the Weather
Channel enough so to actually like
wonder if it's lost its way or not uh so
it kind of makes sense where you can
just look at like what are like for
example you could be like well Court TV
Court TV has been around for or C-SPAN
some of these things have been around
forever you could go and look at what
the revenue is you could see like what's
interesting about them what's not
interesting about them take a new spin
so weather channel is owned by uh it's
that um the guy in Hollywood Byron Allen
I think he was an actor now he's like
one of the richest black men in America
he owns Weather Channel I think they
still make like 500 million a year in
Revenue so like great business we had um
we were friends with this guy named John
who who was the president of BuzzFeed
and he told me he was like man if you
look at CSNBC they only have like 50 000
concurrent visitors or uh viewers on
their on on the channel but they make
this much in Revenue I'm going to create
that but for Facebook live and he ended
up launching cheddar and sold it for
hundreds of millions of dollars and so
like this is like an interesting
strategy of just like looking like which
channels have lived for 50 years and are
doing good but they're just kind of like
been doing the same thing over and over
and over again for a while so it's kind
of actually an interesting strategy
totally agree like building a new
Weather Channel I think is incredibly
complex and complicated but he
definitely has the type of distribution
that could start that business I think
Dennis is like you would need to find a
partner to help him probably execute
that but yeah that that's I think why I
found that the channel so interesting
it's like I go to the weather channel I
even have a widget on my iPhone that
like pops up from it's like automated
from The Weather Channel it gives me the
weather every single day I was like I
would much rather download a Ryan haul
y'all widget that like gave me the
totally much rather support that
um than the Weather Channel and so yeah
I think there's a much it's a pretty
interesting opportunity there for him
you'd made a comment you said something
like you would bet that YouTube will be
five times more valuable than any other
platform combined in terms of value to
from a Creator's point of view of the
type of business you can build on top of
it
um you know more than I do but Sean and
I had made this argument like a year and
a half or two years ago where we're like
man Twitter's like happening in the tech
field but there's not really like a a uh
what's the Kardashian lady uh the Jenner
there's not like one of the gender
persons who've like launched this like
Instagram business that became a billion
dollar company off of Twitter yet but we
think that there's going to be something
there and then Sean was like yeah
there's like the guys on uh the guy
Mafia on Twitter there's like the strip
mall guy there's like the storage guy
and they're actually like raising a
significant amount of investor money to
create some of these companies do you
have you been playing around with
Twitter and seen uh like some of the
micro influencers and the the the the
major differences instead of like um
what you do which is more pop culture uh
this is a little bit more B2B and and
much older but have you paid attention
to like Twitter and played around with
the idea of one of these folks whether
it's like a sweaty startup our friend in
the cuber who's got like a 400 000
following about them building like
pretty big companies in the back Twitter
as opposed to YouTube yeah I've seen it
I'm actually not surprised because I've
I've been pretty outspoken of social
platform where do you build the most fan
loyalty across social and I've seen that
Twitter
is at the top of the pyramid in terms of
fan loyalty like a a Twitter follower
that will comment on your tweets is much
more valuable than a casual viewer on
Tick Tock or Instagram because usually
like they actually care and so I think
people are now starting to figure that
out that oh Twitter is actually
incredibly valuable if you can start to
gain traction and start to get people
that that really engage it's also it's
an older demographic where I think the
one thing that YouTube is really
struggling with right now is you know
yes there's people like Ryan Hall and
there's people like Millennial farmer
who are appealing to maybe a 20 to 30
year old but there it's it's much more
suited for an eight-year-old uh to watch
content whereas Twitter to me is like I
spend most of my time on Twitter uh the
people that I meet on Twitter like I
would buy products from if they actually
promoted something and so I just think
that Twitter for me has been really
interesting from just a fan royalty
perspective uh it's this is the depth of
the platform whereas Instagram and Tick
Tock to me have been more casual
I
I buy things on Instagram but it's rare
and Tick Tock is like my mind share it's
like every single second I'm seeing a
new video I don't even remember the
names of the channels that I see on Tick
Tock they just come and go like I and
when I'm at different events and I see a
lot of tick tock Traders I I recognize
them because I've seen them on Tick Tock
I have no idea what their Tick Tock
channels are which is bad but I will
remember like someone's twitter ads uh
that I see and I'll be like oh my gosh
that's at whatever it is I I very rarely
do I say that about Tick Tock and so I
just think that the depth of consumer is
just much different on Twitter
who would you buy a product from which
are the quote Twitter creators would you
buy a product from or rather who are
some of your favorite follows
I mean I met Blake Robbins which we've
you know did a podcast together I met
him on Twitter that was how he met I
thought his tweets were incredibly
interesting I thought as an investor he
was talking about a lot of things that
interest me and so if Blake would have
sold anything three to four years ago
before I knew him I would have instantly
bought it because he had he had built up
that you know loyalty I bet loyalty like
I not only agreed with a lot of things
he was saying I thought it was really
interesting to the point where I would
take time to comment or like that tweet
and I I have a lot of those now just
that I follow on Twitter and then you
get to like the of it that are getting
hundreds of thousands of likes and I
think you know now then you have the
Bots and you have a lot of internet
trolls and stuff like that but where
Blake kind of sits is in the 30 40 000
follower range and a lot of those people
care about what he's saying and then the
word of mouth becomes really interesting
where someone says hey I used an eight
sleep mattress
um it's changed my life if someone Blake
or you guys tweet that I'm gonna be like
what is an eight-sleep mattress I should
probably figure out why they like this
so much but if someone on Tick Tock is
like oh my eight slate matches well well
I probably just scroll past it and don't
even think twice about it
um so that that to me is like something
that I've noticed
I treated out that I love Aid sleep like
I don't have any affiliation with them
um I just had one of their mattresses
and I tweeted out how much I loved it
and then right away their team reached
out like hey can we do an affiliate deal
or do you ever want to partner together
I'm like no man I just I'm just talking
about cool [__] that I like and so but
they said they they said they they sold
a lot of mattresses from that tweet yeah
the people that follow you also can't
afford the product they you know
probably been following you for a long
time they trust what you say because you
guys aren't Shilling a ton of stuff
constantly so when you authentically
talk about our products like people pay
attention
it's like Tim totally right like I I
used to pay a lot of attention to what
Tim Ferriss was using and talking about
on Twitter
are there any other good follows that
that you have that uh you could see
launching a business and succeeding
um I mean you guys mentioned some really
good ones I it's not a platform that I
pay a lot of attention to in terms of
individuals like that could grow
businesses I think I'm much more suited
for YouTube I live in the depths of
YouTube Every Single Day Twitter for me
is like following people I know you guys
my friends like other people in the
business here
um but we'll see I I hope they're able
to grow businesses on top of it I I have
a lot of confidence in Twitter just as a
platform to be a girlfriend loyalty
what about threads we didn't ask you
about threads
all right if you guys look at the Google
trends for Threads it's not looking good
I also saw a graph this morning on daily
active users for Threads that just like
fell offline
I didn't have a lot of faith in it um
but we'll see I don't think that I I saw
a lot of people talking about that and I
think their takeaway is like oh it's not
working or it failed but like that was
always going to happen even whether it's
going to succeed or not
if they got a hundred million people to
download the app any app look at the
Twitter app will do the same if you get
100 million people in a day to download
the thing you're going to turn like you
know 80 of them won't just start using
the app regularly habitually uh right
away so so to me I see that and I'm like
this is
completely normal and like to me has no
uh like that was gonna happen either way
um there was no chance that 100 million
people are gonna download it and 100
million people are going to keep using
it next week that's no app in the
history of mankind ever has worked that
way and so the question is like what
happens I don't know uh three months
from now once they get their kind of
core base of users does that start
growing or not and well like yeah
there's no way to know until until then
yeah totally agree uh I I haven't logged
on I logged on the first day I
downloaded it and haven't really been on
since so I I there's also like you know
you tell your talent to like keep an eye
on it or would you tell your talent no
we honestly don't care uh it's up to
them most of them will download it and
we'll post on it and see if they like it
I think we'll we'll wait like you said
it's gonna take months to figure out if
this is going to gain traction I think
most of them are just going to patiently
wait I don't think any of our talents
are going to fully lead into threats
they're they're better off putting their
time into making amazing YouTube videos
we did this video Sean and I did this
video like two weeks ago or a week ago
where we were talking about how we liked
that Zuck did this and we were team Zuck
and uh Sean we officially have a new
nickname I don't know if you saw this in
the comments of YouTube but we are
officially now zuck's [__]
that's plural both of us
Cox they call us Cox uh the t-shirts are
getting printed uh we should be all
right I don't know like how we are his
[__] does that mean we are having sex
with his wife or or is he having sex
with our wife it's more like the Mighty
the Mighty Ducks it's like where the
where the Mighty Ducks where this this
this uh the small group of people who
really believe in this thing that
everybody else kind of uh has written
off or hates yeah but we're a cuck so I
don't know who's who's having sex with
whose wife but something is happening
there of which we are involved in uh we
are officially Zex Cox which I'm okay
with I I did yeah I'm a [__] for sure
see well it once once they box or fight
MMA like I'll be in elon's side of the
the Octagon so maybe will you really I
think so I will bet you uh a largest a
large sum of money that if that ever
happens that Zuck would crush him uh
yeah I guess I in terms of who would win
I mean just looking at the pictures that
Mark posted with Israel adesanya and uh
volkanovsky it scares me a little bit if
I'm Elon Musk but I still like I gotta
support you so win or lose
do you um uh last couple questions but
what would you sell night media for
right now I wouldn't I created Knight
because I really enjoy it and what would
I do if I sold that media I'd become an
investor like I already get to do that
so yeah but but there's there's always
there's got to be a number what do you
think it's worth
um man I don't know to be honest uh it
all depends on how you value the
subsidiary Labs businesses I mean I
could probably I know what the core
management company is worth and what
this subsidiary businesses are I think
is like where it could Flex quite a bit
but
sure I enjoy it like I I think if I if I
sold night the acquiring business would
have to make me the CEO like if we sold
it to an agency like they would they
would have to make me the the CEO of
that major agency or management company
because I actually enjoyed doing this
like it's not something like I didn't
start night media to sell night media I
started my media so I was like I really
enjoy what I really want to do this I I
find fulfillment in it I have a venture
capital fund I get to invest I get to
start businesses I get to be
entrepreneurial I get to be a manager
and I get all the perks of being a
manager uh I I don't want to do anything
else right now that might change in a
few years who knows like what time will
do but
yeah I don't know I wouldn't sell we've
had offers like I just wouldn't sell it
so what what
um hundreds of millions of dollars I
would assume low low north of hundreds
of millions of dollars there's no chance
to know
that's that's wild that's a good you're
in a good position to be in right yeah I
mean there's just
I feel like we're I said this about
feasible I I feel this about the whole
company in general is we haven't even
got started it'd be hard for me to to
sell this thing with
the amount of upside that I see over the
next like five years I could see a
partnership of some sort I don't think I
could just fully sell it and walk away
or have like an earn out over multiple
years right now not yet
well you raised a hundred million
dollars or you received 100 million
dollars from chernin in a separate fund
to buy consumer businesses that you
could then kind of like plug in YouTube
distribution into something like that I
think that's the idea can you explain
it's a big idea there and what if you've
done anything with that yet yeah so Labs
will will start a business zero to one
uh feasible was started ground level
race Capital hired the CEO night capital
is more fixated on finding a business
that's generating cash that maybe is
doing 5 10 15 million dollars a year and
we think we can come in uh probably buy
a majority stake in that business roll
some creators or a celebrity out of the
cap table and expand what that business
is doing or just continue to grow that
business it's it's very similar to what
chernin does and is doing with cars and
bids and did with Barstool and hello
sunshine and all these other businesses
yeah they've done that tons of times
yeah a massive opportunity for us to do
it as well just because we understand
this Creator ecosystem and just internet
pop culture so much better than anyone
else and so that ideally is like why we
did that Capital we're not in a hurry to
do a deal I think the economy has been
something that scared us a little bit
and everyone that did deals in 2022 I
think is really regretting a lot of
those uh and so we're just patiently
waiting for what that thing is going to
be well dude we appreciate you doing
this you're the man
um it's always I like just hearing like
what you're tinkering with you have a
very uh interesting uh perspective on
things what do you think Sean yeah this
was fun
um and I'm glad uh I don't know how well
we stuck to our mission but I think it
was pretty good yeah it was pretty good
uh we'll bleep out every mention
um because this is the zero Cloud
podcast zero Cloud chasing podcast and
uh we have a no Cloud policy and we did
not we did not want to do that wait but
do we have to use this face on a
thumbnail
no we're gonna blur it out I think we
have to put like his face and then
Reed's face next to it and blur out
Reed's face and the thumbnails like The
Man Behind the Scenes or something
ridiculous I'll let you guys figure that
one out I mean there's plenty of things
no you got to figure it out we don't
know how to do it we suck at YouTube
guys are killing it so no YouTube is we
have way more downloads on uh on like
the actual podcast uh you know uh iTunes
and stuff like that uh we suck at
YouTube I mean I would argue that a
listener on iTunes or Spotify is
probably way more valuable than a single
listener on YouTube in the podcast genre
so I I think what you guys are doing is
incredible
um and I I would continue to focus on
listens across other platforms I
wouldn't like hedge too highly on
YouTube at the moment I agree that we've
we've we like went hard on YouTube for
like the last 12 months and now it's
like oh man actually the podcast number
that just steadily grows every single
week whereas YouTube it's a little it's
a little lumpy yeah on the opposite I
love YouTube I think it's great I think
I just like the comments I guess I love
it too but I I do think that I I consume
your guys's podcast on Spotify so
yeah it's I guess that's what you get
used to once wherever you consume it
you're like this is a good place for
things and so yeah you know that's where
things go all right Reed thanks for
coming on man where should people uh
follow you or find you a shout out
wherever you want people to go I mean we
spoke a lot about Twitter so let's just
read JD on Twitter
um and then uh I I probably am the most
active on Instagram in terms of like
answering messages so uh same thing read
JD on Instagram so I appreciate you guys
thanks for having me on see ya
it is producer Ben's last day
uh last day producing an episode this is
it this is your uh your Michael Jordan
shot against the Jazz
will there be a Wizard's comeback I
don't know but this might be your
walk-on
all right here's the rules
you can't say anything about next
chapter or Adventure I don't want to
hear that and
um you can't generically say you learned
so much if you say you learn so much you
better tell us exactly what you learned
all right those are the rules for this
speech okay great
um so the next the next thing for me is
basically
focusing on how to take over the world
getting the podcast is as big as
possible speaking things
taking over the world with how to take
over the world speaking of like things I
learned when I was here I think
um people talk a lot about Focus right
and focus is Maybe
easier when things are not going well
because if focuses about saying no the
world is like saying no to you but when
things start going well all of a sudden
the world is like saying yes to you you
have all these opportunities right and
uh so that was I think one of the things
that happened to me early on when I came
on my first million all these people
were like oh Ben Wilson the new hot
thing do you want to try this do you
want to do this what about YouTube or we
should make some shorts you wanna do
Tick Tock and I was like yes yes yes yes
yes yes I want to do like all these
things right and so I had all these kind
of half finished projects that ended up
not going anywhere because I was maybe
a little too dispersed in my attention
so now it's like no no just let's get
the podcast to be one of the best
podcasts in the world that's all I'm
focusing on for the next year and then
we'll see what happens after that
there's nothing better
quitting your job when you have the
twins let alone even one baby
what kind of what kind of responsible
Mormon are you I mean what kind of
decision was this Reckless at best
well I mean it's it's not like I'm
starting from zero right it's not like I
have an idea for a podcast luckily uh
you guys have
um put me in a position where the
podcast is doing pretty well right now
so even if I have a bad year and and it
doesn't grow that much I'll be fine and
if it goes really well then things will
be great so
it's a little bit of a risk but not an
existential risk and do you have I don't
know a message to the fans how do you
want to leave us here where do you want
to go with this so obviously the first
message is go follow how to take over
the world wherever your podcasts you'll
love it my man I guess
um the the most important thing is thank
you guys my life changed uh however a
year and a half ago when uh when you
guys brought me on the show and I called
it the ride of a lifetime but really
like
I didn't know if I would be able to make
a living as a Creator before
you guys brought me on here now I know
that I can do that at least in some
capacity and so my life has completely
changed so so thank you this has been
amazing and I've loved doing it and uh
to everyone who has like supported me
been such a fan cheered for me uh on the
podcast like thank you to you guys the
listeners as well it's meant a ton and
I've loved it so I guess that's the last
thing I'm just very very grateful for
this opportunity I've had the reason I
didn't like celebrate you leaving
because I'm like you're not really going
anywhere you'll be around uh you're just
gonna be unemployed for a little while
and hopefully uh it works out but I'm
sure it will be and I'm happy you kind
of came in our lives uh
it's fun having you around we're hiring
for a producer
yeah uh so we're using what a uh Sean's
Filipino assistance for a little while
but I don't know if that's gonna work
out
um my mom is trying to download Audacity
this morning so we'll see what we can do
yeah
so we need a producer but yeah Ben uh we
love you and thank you for everything
you did you uh you were mostly decent at
a handful of things
it was a Leisure walk uh but it was fine
enough uh no Ben you're amazing uh I I
still listen to all the pods so that's
how I know that uh it's a good point I'm
glad you're doing this because we need
more episodes uh like if you go I've
listened to all the episodes I just need
more episodes so this is good I'm glad
you're doing this
um thank you so much for everything that
you've done you've brought a lot of uh I
don't know good support and good energy
to to what we do we make it very easy
for me and Sam because we just get to
show up perform and then not think about
it after like as soon as we hit done me
and Sam don't really have to think about
anything and uh that's because of you
and a bunch of other people behind the
scenes and so uh thanks for everything
you've done man and we will all go in
solidarity the gentleman's agreement
today you don't subscribe to us you go
subscribe to how to take over the world
fantastic podcast it basically talks
about I don't know great conquerors and
people who achieved greatness and great
things Ben goes and reads like 50 books
and then just summarizes it into one
awesome podcast Story one hour so you
don't have to go read all those books
and you get the story from him so it's
an amazing amazing pod go subscribe
thanks man talk soon
[Music]
foreign